hi there steve coffin here today i want
to talk about learning
using lists
a very common practice in language
instruction
remember if you enjoy these
videos about language learning please
subscribe to my channel
most learning books or many of them will
start with lists for example
i mentioned earlier that i bought this
living language series
and
they not only start with lists they
continue to use lists as far as i can
tell throughout their
uh
you know throughout these books so they
start out with the sounds of the
language that's the list of course the
greek letters is a list then we have
colors
parts of the body
rooms in the house members of your
family numbers
i mean it just goes on fruits and
vegetables everything is a list it
almost doesn't matter which page you
turn to there's a list adjectives are a
list and of course uh grammar you know
present tense different verb types
conjugations uh
demonstrative pronouns it doesn't matter
what it is it's all presented as a list
i find it very difficult to learn from a
list
trying to learn all the colors at once
is much more difficult than gradually
getting used to
green grass blue sky
in other words the use of these
terms
in context similarly you know names of
countries
uh
you know runes in the house it doesn't
matter uh
lists in my opinion
uh are not for learning lists are for
reference
so
once i have been exposed to enough of
the language and i'll explain how i
expose myself to the language
then at some point i may want to see a
list of
colors or
uh vegetables or
conjugation tables or something just to
kind of refresh myself to confirm or to
review
and so but you don't need to buy
a learning system like living language
for that the only advantage with living
language is that they have an online
version
where you have text-to-speech
but if i google uh parts of the body in
greek colors in greek numbers in greek
uh whatever it might be i'll find that
list and increasingly i'll find that
those lists with text-to-speech to help
me with the pronunciation if i need that
so
lists are for reference not for learning
uh
one of the best ways to become familiar
to create that familiarity where you are
kind of grazing and going over the same
material uh
in different situations different
contexts
meeting the same words over and over
again gradually reinforcing your grasp
on all of this one of the best things
i've seen
is those mini stories that i've
mentioned before pyotr at
realpolis.pl developed for learning
polish a hundred many stories each story
consists of a you know
he
got up in the morning he made coffee
brush his teeth and he went to work same
story then told by that person i get up
i do this i do that and then questions
and that's very reinforcing so
i enjoyed using that for polish now as a
result i have commissioned someone to
write stories in english
and these stories are going to feature
different aspects of the structure of
the language we're going to focus on the
more common verbs i think nouns you
can't really control but at least the
most common verbs in different tenses
and different grammatical situations and
the stories are written with a certain
amount of humor
we hope to have eventually a hundred of
them
um we have
15 now
uh in the english library at link with
audio
and i have also now had them translated
into greek
by the internet outsourced and i'm
having them recorded
now even without the audio i have
started using these for greek and i tell
you it's tremendous it's tremendous and
because for gree for me greek it's all
new words there are very few words there
that i so far that i can identify as as
words of greek origin that i've
encountered in other languages very few
it's mostly
stone
cold new vocabulary
uh but so these stories that i'm working
through the 15 that we do have and we're
getting another 15.
i find it very good and what makes it
even better
is using you know we have now at link we
have these four
activities we went away from just flash
guarding so that we have on a random
basis we have these four activities
flashcards
fill in the blank multiple choice and
dictation dictation you hear the
text-to-speech and you have to you have
to then type it out
and
it's fun to do because it's random and i
think randomizing things let's call it
gamification call it randomizing keeps
things fresh
and and i think one of the problems with
reviewing flashcards one after another
or doing lists one after another is that
that the brain requires yes repetition
but also requires novelty as manfred
spitzer the german neuroscientist
pointed out so keeping it random
introduces that element of novelty
otherwise you're getting less and less
fresh every time you're doing the same
thing over and over again
just as
it's very difficult with a list to be as
as focused on the 10th item on that list
as you were on the first item on that
list so all of this to say that
i have seen this overwhelming tendency
to teach things using lists i think it's
counterproductive i think the list
should be made available as a reference
and that learning as stephen krashen
phil rightly points out has to be based
on compelling input compelling content
and eventually that compelling content
is authentic content of genuine interest
but at the level where i am in greek uh
you know i tried importing an article
from a newspaper in greek into link and
it's just too painful to go through word
after word after word that i don't know
uh so you need something simpler
and that's where these stories come in
and if they're written with a little bit
of humor
and with enough repetition it's
something that you can
basically grab a hold of
build up your competence build up your
vocabulary build up your familiarity
with the structures
occasionally review these in lists but
fundamentally spend your time listening
and reading and eventually
hopefully i can catapult mouse catapult
myself into a situation where i can
access authentic content in greek i will
keep you posted thank you for listening
bye for now
[Music]
you